♪ ♪
>> THE PEOPLE OF IRAN WANT
CHANGE, AND OTHER THAN THE VAST
MILITARY POWER OF THE
UNITED STATES, THAT IRAN'S
PEOPLE ARE WHAT THEIR LEADERS
FEAR THE MOST.
OPPRESSIVE REGIMES AND NOT
INDOOR FOREVER, AND THE DAY WILL
COME WHEN THE PEOPLE WILL FACE A
CHOICE.
RETURN TO THE NATION'S PROUD
ROOTS AS A CENTER OF
CIVILIZATION, CULTURE AND
WEALTH, WHETHER PEOPLE CAN BE
HAPPY AND PROSPEROUS ONCE AGAIN?
>> Sean: THAT WAS THE
PRESIDENT -- THAT WAS BACK IN
SEPTEMBER AT THE UNITED NATIONS,
PREDICTING THE UNREST AT THAT IS
NOW SPREADING IN IRAN TONIGHT.
EARLIER TODAY THE PRESIDENT
WAITED SUCH RESPECT FOR THE
PEOPLE OF IRAN AS THEY TRY TO
TAKE BACK THEIR CORRUPT
GOVERNMENT.
YOU WILL SEE GREAT SUPPORT FROM
AMBASSADOR TO THE U.N., FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR JOHN BOLTON, AND
NATIONAL IRANIAN CONGRESS SENATE
CHAIRMAN, PRESIDENT OF THE
IRANIAN RHYTHM INSTITUTE.
WE DON'T HAVE A TIME LIKE YOU
DID A RADIO TODAY TO GET INTO
ALL OF YOUR BACKGROUND.
YOU ARE A STUDENT PUSHING FOR
FREEDOM AND LIBERTY.
YOU WERE IN PRISON IN IRAN FOR
NEARLY SIX YEARS.
EVERY BONE IN YOUR BODY WAS
PEOPLE IN IRAN WERE CHANTING
DEATH TO THE DICTATOR.
DEATH TO AYATOLLAH.
THAT MEANS THESE ARE THE RIGHTS
THAT THE AMERICANS AND THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY SHOULD
HAVE, FOCUS ON THEM AND TO HELP
THEM.
BECAUSE THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO
CAN CHANGE THEIR ENTIRE
MIDDLE EAST AND ENTIRE WORLD.
IF WE CAN CHANGE THE REGIME OF
IRAN, THEN BRING --
>> Sean: THAT WOULD MEAN
RADICAL ISLAMIST MULLAHS THAT
CHANCE DEATH TO AMERICA, AND
DEATH TO ISRAEL WILL NOT BE
MARRIED TO NUCLEAR WEAPONS THAT
THEY SEEK SO DESPERATELY.
>> EXACTLY.
AND IF YOU REALIZE THE FIRST
QUESTION YOU ASKED ABOUT ME, I
DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT MYSELF,
HONESTLY.
THE PEOPLE CAN GO AND GOOGLE MY
NAME.
>> Sean: YOU WERE BEATEN.
EVERY BONE IN YOUR BODY WAS
BROKEN.
>> FOR MORE THAN FIVE YEARS.
AND A LOT OF BONES IN MY BODY
HAVE BEEN BROKEN.
BUT RIGHT NOW MY FRIENDS ARE IN
THE STREET, THERE CHANTING.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU, YOU
HAVE HELPED ORGANIZE WHAT IS
HAPPENING TODAY.
HOW DO YOU WIN A REVOLUTION
WITHOUT WEAPONS WHEN YOU HAVE
THE REVOLUTIONARY GUARD AND THE
OTHER MILITARY?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU FOR
MENTIONING THAT.
IF THEY ARE CALLING THESE
PROTESTS A SPONTANEOUS REACTION
TO HARDSHIPS.
AND THIS IS COMING FROM THE
REGIME.
THAT'S VERY INTERESTING BECAUSE
SOME MEDIA HERE, THIS IS NOT
CORRECT.
THESE KIDS IN IRAN, THEY PLAN
IF THIS IS A REVOLUTION.
>> Sean: WILL THIS BE
SUCCESSFUL?
LET ME GO TO AMBASSADOR BOLTON.
AMBASSADOR, YOU HAVE BEEN AN
ADVOCATE, I THINK WE MADE SUCH A
BIG MISTAKE, AND I'M SURE A MERE
AGREES WITH ME BACK IN 2009.
I DON'T KNOW MANY REVOLUTIONS
THAT WHEN WITH SLINGSHOTS AND
BASEBALL BATS IF PEOPLE AREN'T
ARMED, AMBASSADOR.
MY FEAR IS WE WILL WAKE UP TO A
MASSACRE OF A LOT OF THESE YOUNG
STUDENTS, THAT IS A FEAR THAT I
>> I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
AND I THINK THE UNITED STATES
HAS AN OBLIGATION HERE, THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN CORRECT IN
HIS TWEETS ABOUT SUPPORT FOR THE
OPPOSITION.
BUT WE HAVE, IN OUR PAST, CALLED
OUT OPPOSITIONS INTO THE STREETS
IN HUNGARY AND EASTERN EUROPE IN
THE 1950s, IN IRAQ AFTER THE
FIRST PERSIAN GULF WAR.
AND THEN STOOD BY WHILE THEY
THE VARIOUS ASPECTS OF THE
OPPOSITION, A VERY COMPLEX
PHENOMENON THAT'S GOING ON, AND
HELP INSIDE IRAN BECAUSE THE
GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN EFFECTIVE IN
SHUTTING DOWN, OR SLOWING DOWN
THE INTERNET.
I THINK THEY NEED FINANCES SO
THAT THEY CAN COMMUNICATE BETTER
INSIDE IRAN, AND ULTIMATELY THEY
MAY NEED ASSISTANCE MORE THAN
THAT.
THE OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES, WHICH IS PRETTY
IN IRAN.
HONESTLY, THE PEOPLE WHO KNOW
BEST WHAT THEY NEED ARE THE
OPPOSITION FIGURES INSIDE IRAN.
SUPPORT I THINK WE SHOULD
PROVIDED TO THEM.
>> Sean: WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE
THIS PRESIDENT TO DO, AND HOW IS
THIS GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL?
>> MY FATHER WAS AN AIR FORCE
ARMY OFFICER.
I'M COMING FROM A MILITARY
FAMILY, THE TRADITIONAL MILITARY
ANYONE.
THIS IS TRUE DIFFERENT MILITARY
FORCE AND TRADITIONAL ARMY.
THEY HAVE BEEN WITH THE PEOPLE
FROM DAY ONE.
>> Sean: YOU BELIEVE THEY ARE
TODAY?
>> THEY ARE TODAY.
>> THE REVOLUTIONARY GUARD, A
BODY REVOLUTIONARY GUARDS, RIGHT
NOW THEY ARE TELLING -- THE
COMMANDERS WE CANNOT JUST COUNT
ON THEM.
BUT JOHN BOLTON, I WANT TO USE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SAY
MR. BOLTON BECAUSE HE WAS RIGHT
ALL THE TIME WHEN IT COMES TO
IRAN, HE WAS ON THE RIGHT SIDE
OF HISTORY.
THANK YOU, AMBASSADOR.
ABOUT WHAT THE UNITED STATES CAN
DO, SPECIFICALLY
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
RIGHT NOW, THE PEOPLE IN IRAN,
THEY ARE HUNGRY.
THEY LEFT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WILL HAVE INTERNET COVERAGE ALL
OVER IRAN, SATELLITE INTERNET.
>> Sean: GET THE STORY OUT,
GET THE VIDEOS OUT.
GET THE IMAGES OUT.
HOW BIG IS THIS?
HOW MANY?
>> THIS IS HUGE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT MILLIONS
IF THEY CAN AN ARMY OF THE WORLD
TO